e e
okay I'm going open the meeting okay
thank you all for being here it's 10
o'clock I'm going to open the public
hearing for
sp537 our chairman is uh engaged in
another business so he'll be delayed a
bit so um Jim quy the vice chairman so
the public hearing for SP 537 is
open Senator
Susi thank thank you very much Mr
chairman MERS you you know I've just
been reminded by our helpful clerk I'm
sorry I apologize I'm so excited I I
forgot the Pledge of Allegiance very
good thank you see
sorry alce to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
my apologies Senator not at all happy to
participate thank you very much for
being here certainly and I can verify
that the chair is in Senate election law
at the moment but it's probably going to
be coming back up um I for the record
I'm Donna Susi I represent Senate
District 18 which is comprised of town
of Lichfield and Wards 5 through n in
the city of Manchester and I sponsored
this bill as at a request of the clerk
of Association but in particular my city
clerk Matt Norman who's the clerk in
Manchester um the bill has changed a bit
since um I originally introduced it
there are a couple issues that I will
point out to you um and I I think the
clerks May Echo those concerns as well
but essentially the issue is twofold it
attempts to um
attempts to achieve two goals um number
one is to allow for
pre-processing for the management of
workflow for City and town clerks as we
know particularly the presidential
elections there were a number of
absentee ballots cast having a public
process which to me is critical um
allowing for that
preprocessing does two things as I first
mentioned it would alleviate some of the
time spent on Election Day trying to
Mark a checklist and processing those
ballots which does take significant
amount of time depending on how many are
being processed um but the second issue
is if the pre-processing is done in
advance of election day to the extent
the voter has provided contact
information Beyond just their address
phone number email which is optional but
if they've provided it it does give an
opportunity for voters who have made a
mistake either not signed the envelope
or um you know have left the ballot
outsa an opportunity to cure their
ballot so those were the two goals we
were hoping to achieve with the
legislation um there are a couple things
as I said that I would note that are
different different from the original
version that the clerks will probably um
speak to um but one is about the ballot
curing um the bill as amended now
mandates that the clerk scheduled two
dates to open absentee ballots the
original legislation was just
one um
and to the extent they have to cure I
think the clerks are looking for a
little more precise direction as to what
that means um in many cases it's picking
up the telephone or it's sending out an
email um I think some of that could be
addressed in the election manual but I
think we want to make sure that there's
uniformity in that process
um we also I think wanted to make this
optional um in a place like Manchester
the volume is a little different than in
some of our other towns it may be more
manageable um we want wanted to make it
optional so that it is a
tool
um we have done the process before in
Manchester we did during the 2020
elections when the legislation was for
that specific election
cycle um the logistics were a bit tough
but I think everything worked relatively
well however there was a cost associated
with doing it because wow um we have 12
Wards quite the weather uh 12 Wards and
it was done all in one place so it
required a rental and some other
logistical concerns but um by and large
I'm happy to talk to any to respond to
any questions about specific parameters
of the bill but I do think I would ask
that um you do consider making it
optional so that it is an important tool
and that there be some language that if
voters are if election officials are
directed to cure that that be included
in the election manual that is prepared
by the secretary of state with that I'd
conclude my testimony and be happy to
answer any questions oh thank you very
much do we have questions from the
committee representative
wood thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm a little confused
here we we're talking about mandating
two days and making an optional what are
you looking at making an option optional
so so as I thank you representative wood
as I said the bill originally was
proposed as optional when it got amended
um the amendment which was prepared by
Senator gray that I did go along with
had a requirement that there be two
dates what I was explaining is that that
was not what I had been asked to do by
the clerk's Association so to the extent
you know they will provide more input
that's something that I think we might
want to go back to but I do repres I
want to represent what I was directed to
do
um yeah certainly yeah thank you so uh
the it seems
like it was brought across as a mandate
I I don't understand why we would
mandate all the towns to do something
like this so I I'm just stuck with what
I'm reading right now I and and have a a
problem with that completely so that's
why I'm bringing it up twice sorry and
you did a good job explaining where
you're you're on it but why why was it
felt if you can help help me on this
thank you
um I don't want to speak for Senator
gray as I said he did draft the
amendment um I think he his his ultimate
goal is to sure that as many people who
do cast absentee ballots can participate
in the process so by mandating a cure
section it means that many more ballots
potentially get
counted to the extent a voter is able to
cure whatever deficiency there might
be do we have any other questions from
oh I recognize uh representative Lane
thank you Senator Susi um there was a
mention about handwriting analysis that
this bill might be flipping us back to
handwriting analysis could you speak to
that sure um I think you're referring
there is language about signature right
um that is on page five of the bill
compare the signature on that's language
that I I personally think should be
removed existing language there is no
intent to uh the bill as drafted and as
amended um does not revert back to
Signature comparison um I think there
was litigation right um we were directed
to suspend that practice um because it
was perceived to be disenfranchising
voters I don't think this legislation is
drafted in any way goes back to that but
it doesn't delete the language that has
the signature requirement from the past
yeah follow yeah yes thank you um my
concern is if that we then again pass
the bill that has that in it are we
sending a message to the courts that
were trying to override their decision I
I don't know I that that was just a
concern that I had I didn't know if you
shared it or not I I think that's a
reasonable concern as I say I think my
my personal preference would be to
elimin minate that provision but if you
look it starts on um page four it's
section s um you can see what the
amendments are which is to strike
through open the envelope and instead
replace it with process absentee and
then when you get to the next page the
signature language was what was already
there
okay okay sorry about that just doing
double duty actually it was at just at
your committee um we were we were
switching Mr chairman and I'm going
right back down in a minute so um any
other further questions from the
committee um I have yes represent one
more I'm sorry I one more question um in
here it's mandated for two days and um
in would it be better for cities or
towns that don't have that many to have
the option of up to two or I mean was
there a re specific reason to was
selected yeah that was the question that
representative would asked me so my bill
as originally drafted did have the
option um of doing
pre-processing um in order to get
a unanimous vote out of the Senate on
the legislation um the amendment was
drafted to require it the reasoning
behind requiring it for those that
supported it was to ensure that as many
deficient
ballots that would not have enabled able
to be counted could be cured in advance
that was the reasoning for it
so yes thank you but there was no
specific reason why two was picked I
mean because many could do it in one was
that a change I'm sorry if I'm if you've
already answered that I'm not following
yeah I didn't I didn't answer the
question as to two and honestly I can't
speak to it I can just tell you that it
was the committee chair's preference it
Senator Gray's preference that there
too are there further questions from the
committee oh yes representative HR thank
you um if an error is found when we open
up the ballots the affidavit is not
signed or something how do we contact
the
people so that's the question that I
think would need to be
addressed in the election manual so that
there is a uniform process right now we
request um but it is optional inform uh
information including telephone number
and email
address those would be the methods by
which you could contact a voter um and
if you're pre-processing there's time to
do that I think the clerks can give you
more specificity as to the process they
used during covid when they did a lot
more of this but I think the concept
would be to include Direction in the
election law manual provided by the
Secretary of
State uh further questions from the
committee okay last call for questions
from the committee I seeing none thank
you very much senator for speaking with
us thank you very much
Mr okay
uh next person up to testify is Linda
Bundy thank you for joining us today my
pleasure um representative qua and other
members of house election law my name is
Linda Bundy I'm from antrum and I
support SP 537 allowing the processing
of absentee ballots My Town Clerk and
moderator are in favor of allowing
pre-processing of absentee ballots
during the 2020 elections they
encountered a number of ballots with
inner envelopes that had errors or
omissions in each instance they were
able to contact the voter who then came
and completed the envelope correctly the
voters were pleased and grateful for
this opportunity that ensured their vote
votes would be counted with larger towns
and cities in addition to providing
voters a way to cure their ballots
pre-processing can make counting the
ballots on Election Day more efficient
for election
workers the Senate house election and
Municipal Affairs committee unanimously
voted this bill OTP and the full Senate
approved it by a Voice vote I ask that
you do the same and vote ought to pass
on S SP 537
thank you thank you uh you available to
take
questions yeah sure okay well are there
any questions from members of the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much for speaking with us thank
you okay next uh person to testify Tina
okay thank you very much for joining us
good morning committee uh my name is
Tina Guilford I'm the town clerk in
Derry I was the moderator in Derry in
2020 um we pre-processed ballots for the
November election and it went great this
gave residents the opportunity to come
in and cure
defaults um many people forget to sign
the envelope it it is probably one of
the number one reasons for an absentee
ballot being
rejected I supported this bill in the
Senate I testified in support of it and
I still support it I do however have a
couple of
concerns when the bill uh was originally
introduced it addressed RSA 659 colon
49 there's two things in that part of
the
statute um and that part of the statute
um specifically
says that
[Music]
um that ballot processing shall begin at
1 p.m unless at a different time that is
no earlier than two hours after the
opening of the
polls however this part says that you
may open absentee ballot outer envelopes
on Election Day at any time after the
opening of the polls so I think we have
two statutes in conflict
also um the original Bill uh removed
part two of RSA 659 colon 49 uh which
upon the written challenges of 10 or
more voters who are present at the polls
no later than 1 pm the might
pre-processed these ballots um so again
I think there is a little bit of
conflict here and I think that's
something that you need to
address uh my other largest issue issue
is that um there are a couple of
different spots in here that
state um for example um on page three
line 22 absentee ballots returned to the
town or city clerks in person shall not
be required to be placed in such outer
envelopes which is great we can save
some trees my problem is is that has
anyone sometimes tried to decipher a
signature to see who that ballot belongs
to
and my concern is is that we attach the
application to the
envelope I don't know how other towns do
it but we paperclip it because we don't
want to staple it we don't want to put
any holes through the absentee ballot
that's inside that affidavit
envelope well all you need is the box to
knock over and now all of a sudden
everything separates and now you really
don't know which one goes to which
without sitting there and examining
signatures it's a lot easier with the
name and address on the outer
envelope I I'm okay with not having the
outer envelope what I would love is If
On The Backs side of the affidavit
envelope there were pre-printed lines
where people could put their name and
address so that that way it would be
easier to keep it all organized in case
for some reason they become separated
from the
application um I'm just thinking about a
real world
issue um there are some other um
questions about um curing the defaults
and what have you um hopefully that
would all be addressed by the election
procedure manual um as to whether we
would need to issue a second absentee
ballot and and all of that uh but
hopefully that would be addressed in the
election procedure manual and I am happy
to take any questions thank you do we
have any questions from the committee
represent sentive warry thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking my
question and approximately how many
ballots you know percentage wise or
quantity wise did were needed to be
cured in that
manner so I looked real quick at the
presidential
primary
um
we we had
about um 10% that were
rejected and half of them were because
they were missing a
signature and and were you how what
percentage of that half were you able to
oh so um you're talking about in
2020 um that's when we last
pre-processed okay uh so going back to
2020 um of the ballots we rejected in
preprocessing a good 60% of them were
cured we pre-processed on the Thursday
and Friday
prior to election day and our clerk um
had hours on Saturday and
Sunday um for absentee ballots and we
had people come in um in fact we were on
TV during the pre-processing um I know
there are new stations you can probably
Google it we actually had people because
we were actively calling them as we were
getting the rejections and we had people
come in in person while were
pre-processing to fix their
ballots um so it was a lot of people
were able to cure their default um and
were able to vote and have their ballot
counted another another followup yes um
and I'd like to just uh touch on the
suggestion you made with regard to the
backside of uh writing of the name and
address on the application envelope do
you have any concerns with voter privacy
or privacy of the vote if that's
done um that somehow the and people
opening up the envelope that might see
and so normally when you're processing
an absentee ballot you're opening the
outer envelope which has their name and
address on it you announce their name
and then you pull it out and then you
open the second envelope I mean it's all
done at the same time so the
information's already there okay and the
people who are processing them are doing
so off a list list that also has their
information further questions from the
committee uh I I do have a question uh
and a followup uh thank you for taking
my question uh when you say curing the
ballot I I presume you meant curing the
affidavit yes curing curing the default
whatever that default may be and a
followup to that uh you mentioned that
you were able to to fix quite a a number
of those what percentage of the one of
the
uh the affidavits you tried to get in
contact with the voter what percentage
could you not get in contact with rough
yeah roughly there were probably four or
five that did not give us any contact
information be it a phone number or an
email cuz those things are optional on
the application so I if they don't put
it on the application then we have no
way really of getting in contact with
them this was also only a few days
before the
election um you know there there are you
know the clerk processing that they're
talking about is you know you can do it
as early as three weeks prior to the
election so that would give a lot of
time I as a clerk I could mail the
resident a letter and they would
hopefully get it and still be able to
come in and and a lot of the people who
um voted absentee and and had an issue
um and it's the missing signature or
they don't send the affidavit envelope
back at all um some of those people
could not come in uh when we did the
pre-processing because they were
traveling they were not here anymore so
um and I had a few people be like well
it's not like I can come and fix it now
um um in wherever right I'm sorry I
tried okay well thank you do we have any
other questions from the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you uh next
uh person to testify Olivia
zinc well we've seen you a number of
times in our committee good morning
members of the election law committee uh
for the record my name is Olivia zinc a
voter in Franklin and represent open
democracy and nonpartisan uh nonprofit
here in conard um it's really important
um that we listen to the election
workers who really like this idea of
opening the outer envelopes and making
sure we're correcting ballots that a uh
a voter may have made a um mistake it's
not a common practice for them to
understand what these affidavits mean
did they sign the left side did they
sign the right side um during in 20120
when we had pre-processing um it did
save a lot of time on Election Day um 39
States permit some sort of
pre-processing or opening of the outer
envelopes um and I think it's really
important this is a nonpartisan measure
um to lessen the strain of election
works and speed up the time of tallying
um and making sure our ballots are
secure and accurate I also have um
testimony from our um public policy uh
fellow who's a college student and
oftentimes college students are uh
voting um and I think it's also
important for um you know many of the
college students may not have read the
400 pages of election law and understand
it all and so they might need yeah I
mean some of them might have read the
400 pages of the manual but some of them
may have not and and um they don't know
all of the ins and outs on how to how to
do them and so you know we could also
address this by U making sure the
instructions are are as clear and I just
also wanted to point out um that
um uh this also talks about on page four
line 20 um for voters that are um are
blind and voting with a disability and I
do think that
um uh voters with disabilities uh
especially print disabilities have
trouble knowing where to sign on those
applications so assistance is required
for those voters and with that I'm happy
to take good in questions okay thank you
do we have any questions from the
committee uh I see none so thank you
very much for your
testimony uh next Dan
Healey and thank you for being here
today hi uh Dan Healey uh representing
New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association uh where I'm the current
president uh so our
association um we don't want to be
mandated to have the pre-processing we
like some clerks like doing it some um
we want the option so the original Bill
had the had the option I think this bill
uh the amendment changes that a little
bit um and the other concern that I've
heard uh which Tina spoke on was the
curing um so there needs to be a
specific process outlined for the curing
of the absentee ballots um if a resident
sends they're in Florida they send their
absentee ballot to us and they don't
have the signature what is our process
are we sending them the ballot back for
them to sign it are we sending them a
new ballot I think that needs to be uh
spelled out so the election procedure
manual is recommendations from the state
but I think that it should be uh
outlined what the actual process is
that's one of the concerns I've heard um
from another clerk uh during this this
process um my personal opinion on the
bill is that I um I spoke in favor of
the original bill in the Senate I
believe the original Bill uh that was
proposed by Senator Susi um accomplished
everything that the clerk's Association
wanted and I believe the original bill
without any of the Amendments um is
superior to the current the current bill
and I'd be open to any questions okay
thank you do we have questions from the
committee thank you yes representative
Brennan thank you is it your
understanding that the um procedures
that you would like to be um outlined
for you is it your understanding that
that needs to be written into statute or
is it sufficient to have it in the
election procedural manual um issued by
the Secretary of State's office so I
mean I would like a procedure
written um the the election procedure
manual what it is if it's not in law
it's guidance from the state so it's not
required to then do it that way it's
more of a it's a guidance from Secretary
of State's office so if it's in law
that's what we need to do so if you have
it as a procedure clerks could could
have their own procedure for curing the
ballot I think something should be
spelled out for the clerks to make it so
everyone's doing the same thing and
there's no issues with with the
process followup please yes thank you um
does that run contrary to the clerk's
position of not wanting a mandate for
the
pre-processing so as in um the position
of the clerks Association was that this
amendment makes it mandated that
pre-processing occurs
but if there is um a procedure outlined
in the statute does that not make it a
mandatory procedure and are those two
things in Conflict they wouldn't be in
Conflict so if you chose if a clerk
chose to do the
preprocessing that's when they'd see
that inner envelope and they they'd
realize if the um the voter didn't sign
it but if they're not doing the
pre-processing they wouldn't then see
that envelope until election day you
want to you want to be opening the
outside envelope to then see the
affidavit envelope until until election
day unless there was
pre-processing yes representative
Lane uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Healey um for
testifying
um did the original Bill have those cure
Provisions in it and I have not read the
original bill I apologize I I don't
believe it it did um that's something
that's come up over the last few weeks
talking with some of the other clerks um
especially the larger communities that
they get a significant amount of
absentee ballots that if they were to
pre-process they want to know what
they're going to do with that ballot I
mean should they be mailing a completed
ballot back to someone just for a
signature or should we be mailing a a
new ballot Alto together like what
should we be doing some of the the
residents I mean they're local they just
can't be there on Election Day so they
can come and they could sign it but if
we're mailing it if we have to mail back
a completed ballot is that something
that we should be doing say sending it
to Florida a belt that's already filled
out back to the voter I have a follow
have a follow yes certainly U thank you
um if we put say like skeletal cure
stuff and then leave it to the Secretary
of State to kind of elaborate on those
would that be something that I
mean they could provide the guidance
that you wanted around the skeletal
Provisions that we put in I I think that
would be a good option um I think clerks
are just looking for some type of
guidance on what they would have to do
to cure the
ballots yes representative Barry thank
you I'm sorry I'm I'm in and out our
friends in this Senate got me my steps
in today um I I missed questions so have
you addressed the mandatory part of this
bill and the clerk's Association stance
on it being a forced requirement I I
spoke on it briefly um Tina also uh der
town clerk spoke on this um we're not in
favor of mandating it so we would like
an option for for the clerks to decide
if that's what they want to do in their
Community if it makes sense for them to
pre-process or not to pre-process so
we're not our association's not in favor
of of a mandate we do like having the
option to
pre-process any other questions from the
committee yes representative
wry thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
Mr Healey for taking my question just
just to clarify what
um what's the decision-making process
then that that the clerks are looking
for in in terms of whether to
pre-process or not is there I it's it's
almost a followup to representative
Brennan's question is trying to
understand the the
rationale um
for what the clerks are are when the
clerks are just choosing to make a
pre-processing event or not and how we
and understanding how then if you want
that sort of specificity and regulation
what do we need to do to accomplish that
so I'm I'm just trying to if you'll bear
up with my questioning um understand
this a little better so that we can make
sure we get the best possible bill here
yes so I I think it depends on the
volume so in 2020 uh when I was in Derry
we had around 7,000 absentee ballots um
so to be able to pre-process at that
time was extremely helpful um when you
have a town election and we're at a 100
ballots you know it's not really it's
not really going to save us much time on
Election Day to pre-process those those
hundreds so I think it it really depends
on the quantity um in the availability
of people to come in and actually do the
pre-processing and all that but I think
it it it more ties with the quantity I
looking at the records in nashaa they
had around 15,000 absentee ballots in
2020 so um I mean that was beneficial to
them it's a few it would be a few
thousand per Ward which takes a
significant amount of time so to be able
to get a start on processing them prior
to the election was was helpful but you
know for our municipal election when we
only have a couple hundred absentee
ballots spread out across the whole city
it's not really a a time saer when it
comes to uh election day
further
questions representative rafter yes
thanks thanks for taking my question um
I think we all understand why the
Mandate is a kind of a burden but if
it's optional don't we end up with some
towns doing it some towns not so voters
across the state are not treated equally
they're they're being um processed based
on what town they live in shouldn't we
have a consistent uh approach across the
state to treat all voters equally yeah
that is a good point I believe in 2020
it wasn't um mandated across the state I
think it was an option for the
pre-processing in 2020 so some
communities took advantage of it and and
some some didn't yes representative
Barry so we keep talking about 2020 what
about 2022 what have the numbers done
since 2020 because 2020 was in the
noraly so what have they what do they
look like now I would say our best
comparison is going to be this upcoming
year um in the midterm years it's not um
it's not an even
comparison
um I want to say we
had around 3,000 absentee ballots in
nsha for the the
midterm um and in 2020 we had 15,000 the
big comparison is going to be coming up
in in November to see how many we we
have now that we're we're out of
that yes representative Barry may have a
followup um yeah so I I little question
there you say it's not comparable but
we're not talking about we're talking
about the percent of the votes cast
being absentee ballot not the total
number so wouldn't directly comparable
be like 2016 I would also say that 2022
is directly comparable it was a
Statewide general election with Federal
elections on the ballot and while we can
have a conversation about the gross
number uh the percentage is what matters
so what was the percentage of absentee
ballots cast in 2022 and how does that
justify us bringing in this covid change
forever I I don't have that number off
the top of my head I can tell you that
um in 2016 in Derry there were about
1,200 absente ballots for uh
presidential election and in 2020 there
are about 7,000 so I that I guess would
be the best comparison on you know the
difference the
increase um because of
uh because of Co and all that um the the
jump in absentee
ballots I don't I don't expect to get as
many as we did in 2020 for absentee
ballots that's my um my personal opinion
I think the absentee numbers are going
to go down a little bit I don't know
what that number is going to be um but I
want to I want to say without having the
numbers in front of me in
2022 in Nashua I want to say we have had
around 3,000 when in 2020 we had about
15,000 go ahead so couldn't we compare
like the first in the nation
presidential primary because neither of
those have happened during covid so
neither those had the real the real
change so couldn't we look at those
numbers so couldn't we look at 202 uh
2024 uh first the nation primary and
compare it to say 2016 or even
2020 I I could um I could look at my
numbers for the presidential primary
that again is not it's not um as high of
a Turnal you have a lower percentage of
Voters turning out for that
election
um in 20120 we're closer I think we were
closer to like 90% in presidential
primary it wasn't anywhere anywhere near
that so it's it's tough it's it's it's
hard to compare different election types
to each other for
it has to kind of be the same type of
election to to really get an accurate
number representative Brennan thank you
um is it appropriate to say that it
would be the clerk's association's
position that something like this would
generally increase efficiency and is
that not something that is very
important to the state of New Hampshire
that our elections are run
efficiently so for the the
pre-processing just to to verify
um there's there's positives and
negatives for it uh with with the clerks
um I know that some clerks have reported
significant costs for pre-processing as
well so to take on that burden um to for
a larger Community um that may need to
rent a space it was tens of thousands of
for the pre-processing for the staff the
time the space rental um so there
there's positives and negatives to both
and that's why we kind of believe that
it should be a uh decision uh for the
municipality
on um what they want to
do further questions from the
committee representative prud M Brien
thank you thank you for take uh taking
my question thank you for being here
it's always great to hear from you and
um hear about the association as well do
you think it would make sense and it
would be prudent to wait and
see we don't know how much people want
to absentee vote in 2024 until after
2024 and then we'll understand if that
trend has continued and people want to
do it because I I agree 2020 was very
unusual you think that would be
prudent um my my opinion on that is I I
want to stick with the option I think
having the option for clerks is probably
still the best the depending on the
numbers that the clerk can decide to do
it or or not to do it um based on what
they reive for
absentees so I wouldn't hold off on on
the bill but um
our position kind of still as of the
option further questions from the
committee uh seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify I don't see any further red
slips
here uh seeing no one interested in
testifying at this point I am going to
close the public hearing at 10:40
5 take that
yep
okay okay and we're back
um I'm G to open up the notice executive
session for the house election law
committee um we will recess the ex uh
executive session for how long would you
like representative Lane for your
caucus 15 minutes okay we will reconvene
at 11 11:00 um for a brief uh executive
session because I have to go to work so
all right see you at
11:
e
e e
okay are we ready I'm going to reopen
the public notice executive session for
the uh house election law committee uh
we'll start with uh Senate Bill 534
relative to campaign Finance uh I will
recess uh Senate Bill 534 uh I will tell
you what's going to happen with this uh
representative Lane is going to get a uh
we we only have these are our last two
bills we have um I'm not going to bring
the committee back for one to exec one
bill because that would be ridiculous um
so what we what representative Lane is
going to do is she's going to prepare an
amendment she'll circulate it uh to me
and I will uh send it to via the clerk
and myself uh and we'll do a uh we'll do
one of those either during lunch or
during uh a post session we'll do an ex
quick exec on the amendment um so that
way no one has to drive to conquer for
one bill um yes representative Mirad I
think representative Alexander has
volunteered to get lunch for the
committee oh yes I think he did at our
lunch time yeah I only eat chop house so
um Good Luck all right uh so now we will
open up um the executive session for uh
Senate bill 537 allowing the
pre-processing of absentee ballots
representative Lane is recognized for a
motion um I recommend a to pass is there
second representative Brendon second is
there any discussion on the
bill hearing none clerk will call the
role I'm sorry uh would you like to
speak uh no okay uh the motion is not to
pass from representative
Lane
okay um
I I'm glad that uh representative Raptor
brought up what he did about the um
different treatment of different voters
which is something that went through my
mind as I watched this process in 2020
which was a a a a good thing in 2020 but
I was concerned about that when it was
happening
and I'm also not sure that we're going
to have as much of a need in the future
and I I will um revisit this in the
future if that's the case but for those
reasons I'll be voting no so I just
wanted to explain that thank you further
comments from the committee and
recommendation of ought to pass on
Senate Bill I've already forgotten the
number 537 thank you just digging from
my sheet which is of course at the very
bottom any other comments hearing none
the clerk will call the
role uh representative promo Brien no no
wait qu representative qua sorry it's
okay no
representative Poma Brian no
representative Ankerberg no
representative Burnham no Representative
warry no representative wood no
representative Osborne nope
Representative kab no representative
Alexander
no uh uh representative Lan yes
representative Ward yes representative
hamr yes represent
yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes chairman Barry chair votes no
with that the motion of op to pass fails
on a vote of 10 to 10 uh representative
qua is recognized for a new
motion I move that we uh the committee
recommend inexpedient to legislate for
sp537 is there a second representative
Alexander seconds is there any
discussion on the motion of inex speed
to
legislate um very quickly um this bill
is not necessary U it was necessary in
2020 um we've opposed bringing in the
covid changes making them permanent uh
even the testimony we heard today could
not justify this bill today um the I
made that point in my questioning the
numbers have gone back to normal so
there is no I was actually surprised I
thought there would be what I was foring
as a absentee ballot hangover um they
usually average around anywhere between
8 to 10% usually around 10% depending on
the municipality um we've seen them go
below 15% again so we're back to normal
um there's no reason to make this
election law change um election day
needs to happen on Election Day every
time you handle those ballots you it's
not even mischievous it's not malice it
just invites the opportunity for
mistakes people make mistakes um so
there's really no reason for this um
making it mandatory is it attempts to
fix the problem of two classifications
of Voters I recognize that um my thing
is is we could have one classification
of Voters one that has their ballot
processed on Election Day so um I did
circulate a letter from my city clerk uh
when he called me uh usually when my
city clerk calls me uh very very great
city clerk I think he runs one of the
best operations in the state he is the
is obviously the largest election
operation in the state normally when he
calls me uh we're going to have a very
gentlemanly disagreement um and I was
stunned when he told me that this was a
must defeat bill um because he had
spoken to me at length before about why
he liked Parts about pre-processing so
the reason that's the reason I
circulated that letter um when people
who have historically asked me to pass
something say hey Ross this isn't the
one um then this is not the one this
bill is this bill needs a lot of work um
so it's not necessary it needs a lot of
work and it is not universally loved by
the clerks um so with that uh the clerk
will call the RO on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate representative
qua
yes representative pom O Brien yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kab yes representative
Alexander yes representative Lane no
representative Ward no representative
Hammer no Representative hamblet no
representative Mirad
no uh representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
Grill no representative Howard no
Representative rter no chairman Barry
chair votes yes with that the motion of
ought to pass I ined to legislate fails
on a vote of 10 to 10 um I will be
responsible for the inexpedient to
legislate report representative Lane
you'll be responsible for the a to pass
report a reports are due today at 5: um
and with that uh this will be the last
time we meet in notice session I'll see
you guys for a the world's hopefully
quickest executive session on our final
campaign Finance vote which is very
fitting that it'll be the last one so
see you guys later
thanks
e
e for